as
mata says the vw polo has its gti
version
and the ds3 has its racing the sports
car variant of citroen's compact model
and now there's a limited edition of 100
convertibles
it's not a full convertible as these
side rails remain
in place when the roof's down but then
you can also open it when
zipping along
and then it's time for fun in the sun
hardly any of its competitors offers a
convertible version
let alone with this kind of performance
the ds3 racing's 1.6 liter engine
can harness 152 kilowatts of power
that takes this little rocket from zero
to 100 in just six and a half seconds
top speed is 235 kilometers an hour
the ds3 racing may be fast but is it
also fast on the curves the potential is
there
but you need a steady hand
mantis reminds us of a problem with all
powerful front-wheel drive cars
including the ds3 racing
when you really step on the gas the
engine has a powerful effect on steering
it's not nearly as nice as in an
all-wheel drive
or a rear-wheel drive car
what certainly is nice is the exterior
of the ds3
which also works in the rag top version
although the ds3 is known for its
customizing options
the racing version is available only in
the matte moon dark body color
plenty of carbon defines the racing's
look
one quirky trait is the cargo hatch
having left the roof open and want to
stow your purchase you'll need patience
first the roof has to shift upwards and
then
you can open the hatch
the ds3 convertible offers 245 liters of
cargo space
but loading isn't simple because all
you've got is a cramped
and impractical opening
but back to the roof better to close it
before going shopping anyway
if only for security's sake
the completely open roof also has its
disadvantages
think visibility
when the roof is down the rear view
mirror is blocked
even if you turn around you can't see
much but the generous side mirrors and
big windows do help
and taking curves you should be looking
forward anyway
on country roads the ds3 turns into a
little power pack
that keeps its driver comfortable
mata says he especially likes the
seating he's well positioned with good
lateral support
side bolsters aren't too stiff and give
a little if you're a bit wider in the
waist
the only thing that could be bigger is
the actual seat it's a bit short
this is relative quartz inside we find
reflections of the
exterior color scheme again lots of
carbon
and the racing is especially pretty when
you let it sink
hear that it's the sound of excitement
and when the roof's down you hear it
even more the racing takes its name
seriously it accelerates fast breaks
fast
takes curves well and is fun when
shifting
if it only weren't for that stiff
steering during fast curves
the ds3 racing convertible is definitely
a fun car
but personally mantis wouldn't pay such
a high price for a car
in which the fun factor far outweighs
the practical side
thirty eight thousand four hundred
ninety euros in germany isn't exactly
spare change
but perhaps the idea being one of only
one hundred
is compensation and the enjoyment factor
could clinch the deal so if you like
muscle design
and exclusivity you might just fall for
the ds3 racing